hi this is presh talwalkar let's discuss
the monty hall problem
you're on a game show where you have the
choice to pick door number one two or
three
behind two of the doors is nothing and
behind one of the doors is the car
you pick door number one the host who
knows the location of the car shows you
door number two is nothing
do you stay on door number one or do you
switch to door number three
switching to door number three is
actually the much better choice
statistically even though it seems like
staying and switching should not matter
let's do an experiment to illustrate why
we are going to randomize the location
of the car and we're going to imagine
picking one of the doors
where the car isn't and deciding whether
it's better to stay on door number one
or switch to door numbers two or three
whichever one was not empty
initially it seems like staying or
switching does not matter
but as we do the experiment a hundred
times we find that switching is a much
better strategy
almost two times better than staying
the reason is that when you stay you
only win when the car was initially
behind door number one
when you switch you will win if the car
was behind doors number two or three
the monty all problem seems like a
paradox because of how it stated
imagine the host tells you
look you can stay on door number one
and you'll win
only if the car is behind that door
or i'll allow you to switch
to win on doors number two or three
and by the way when you switch i'll open
one of those doors where the car is not
behind
now it's obvious that switching allows
you to win for two doors whereas staying
only allows you to win for one door
please subscribe to my channel i make
videos on math and game theory you can
support mind your decisions on patreon
to get exclusive rewards
you can also catch me on my blog mind
your decisions on twitter at
preshtalwalker or get my books at amazon